yeah welcome to this
broadcast sometimes a little bit tricky
here because of this delay you're
starting the broadcast you're asking
yourself okay is it really on yeah I
think it is on I see it now on my own
twitch
window yeah here we go again for one
hour of live chess
I'm playing a little bit myself or I
might also do commentary on a game that
I kibbit on um I haven't started a game
yet was having a look around if there's
any attractive game to watch there's
some game running here but I will
definitely play some on my own last week
I did um kibit sing for the London chess
Classics Blitz tournament but this time
there's not such a high profile event
around so I will play a little bit
myself you have to have to be content
with that no super GMS blitzing okay I'm
going for a five minute game and see if
I get a game I get one and a funny game
in a way playing Vita from Belgium this
International Master Stefan docs and why
is this funny it is funny because
yesterday I had a match with my German
club in the Germany third league and uh
this guy was playing on the opponent's
team we're not playing um against each
other but he was playing on board two
and I was playing board one so we were
just uh well 2 met away yesterday and
now we play on the IC it's quite quite
funny okay we get a modern defense and
up playing with
C3 this is um very
solid setup I get a request for the
Kings Gambit yeah I will
try I will try maybe I just played
Knight F3 out of um routine in a
way okay Knight A3 that's a good setup
here going for Knight C2 supporting the
center and um let's see how he's playing
this Knight to D7 H yeah he might try to
prepare a f
maybe Knight
C2 what was his power
level I don't
know is Vita some sort of
uh um character out of a movie or
something a power level sounds like
there was um something like that okay
played
F5 let's think about
this I probably want to
capture and use
um the weakened King side somehow but I
don't see at the moment how to do that
well he's not threatening to take on e4
that
much maybe Knight F6 is a move that he
can
try okay I'll start with that ah cartoon
character
uh I didn't know that that this is a Kon
character okay Knight takes F5 yeah this
was probably not the most
um precise way to play Black here
definitely is is all
right yeah if I take F5 he will take D3
this will be very much okay for
black h yeah I don't know this is this
not really a
success this whole this whole game I was
actually planning Queen C4 check which
runs into
D5 huh quite
embarrassing yeah but I really don't
know what else to do yeah I can go to
B3 that really was a big
failure no maybe it's not that bad
I'm always an
optimist maybe Knight D4 can can help
Knight D4 here trying
to push this bishop back
or I mean if he takes um I definitely
have gained something yeah I think I'm
not in such a bad shape actually he also
has to yes exactly he has to think about
me capture ing Knight E6 is possible
but a bit of a self
pin yeah maybe bishop D2 or
something Bishop E3 Bishop E3 looks
looks fine after C5 I draw back his
pawns are mostly weak so it's not a big
problem Queen D7 is a bit
mysterious I don't
know C4 yes C5 so probably I have to
drop back here maybe bishop D4 also move
coming plus
C4 um how much do I think commentary
affects my rating yeah it does I think
about 100
points my my best rating before before I
did commentary was
um something like um on the high end of
2,500
80 um there's a qu oh sorry if I take
now is can take on
F2 H it's not
good but I have count C play I have
counter
play with Rook F1 and Knight
G3 I can go Rook F1 now was my idea or
does he have a great intermediate move
here I was thinking that King G7 Rook F1
Queen F1 Rook F1 Rook F1 Knight G3 for
Knight H5 check this gives me big
counter
play um there's a question about the
book The Modern BOGO yeah I have it I
have to use it as a comparison to my to
my book
project um it is
okay it is um with every book that sort
of yeah you have to to to to choose what
lines to cover what lines to not cover
and um
wow Rook takes H3 mate what a move
oh
great um that is tough
um King
H1 Bishop H3
wow
um I don't see a move King H1 he can
play Bishop H3 yeah but I didn't really
have anything
else yeah there
is yeah it's just it's just it's just
over wow Rook F3 was a great
shot great
shot yeah have to resign
that
wow that was a killer move yeah Rook F3
he I mean it was something that he he
must do I mean otherwise I'm better but
uh wow that's great
okay try for a new
game
[Music]
um got a question
uh about my weight loss yeah I lost a
little bit of weight it's uh just a
change of diet I'm not big big in terms
of
sports Rook D3 yeah maybe Rook D3 E1
hangs though so
it was I would just I don't do any
sports
really
um okay a new game eood ehot I don't
know 45 any requests on openings yeah
it's not fortunately not very rich real
time so I'm just trying to vary a little
bit going for a sicilian yeah they all
Play Bishop B5 nowadays yeah you don't
get the sesn call for enterprising
openings like that very
much okay I'm taking with the B Pawn
this is a little bit more exciting than
taking with the D
Pawn let's
see yeah I know this looks wow at B4
okay I'm I'm taking
this just grabbing the pawn
I don't think that this is so great
really I mean white probably has some
compensation but I don't think it's that
brilliant C4 okay he's got a nice Center
here but not easy to to get
um to make progress
here A5 Bishop
A6
um there's a question about the the
German opening Series compass that I do
for the IC in fact um this series is on
hold at the moment we have not um there
is no plan at the moment to continue it
is simply the case that the German
language videos um didn't uh get much
views so um I will definitely do more
content for the IC but it will be on in
English
probably um do you post this video on
YouTube yes it will be on
YouTube maybe tomorrow maybe the day
after that something like
that um okay so he's playing Queen A4
for some play against the A5 Pawn h n C6
is
hanging I can go Queen C7
but yeah he's got some pressure that's
clear maybe Queen D7 that's then he's
got D5
H not
easy yeah he's got compensation for the
pawn I'm not sure if it is enough but it
is something Rook C1 is a move now that
uh comes to mind
making yeah trying to put more pressure
on C6 even okay he's playing it uh in a
more direct
fashion
okay if I take
here yeah C6 is just hanging yeah maybe
Rook
C8 he's got Knight D4
but I have Knight E5 but Knight E6 H not
easy he definitely has pressure
I cannot take D5 here
unfortunately I take
here n that's ugly
stuff very ugly position he has a really
good position now Knight take C6 I was
thinking maybe Knight E5 just to get rid
of this bloody Knight on on
C6 yeah I know it looks like swiss
cheese but I have to get rid of the
knight uh maybe still Knight
d8 ah not
good this is ugly
stuff H do not play like that guys it's
really
bad
um I do not know what video topic I do
for ISC um there are a couple of
interesting
um um a couple of interesting um
projects coming up on ICC and I will be
involved but we are not completely
finished on the
details yeah I definitely need to do
something here
with with with my my Bishops and I
managed to activate them a little bit at
least Rook B8 maybe this is not that bad
at least they are sort of in the
game but still it's the Swiss cheese
formation and I'm not even a pornup or
I'm actually I am a pornup that's good
news should do a count
sometime and the Bishops yeah Bishop to
D2 is something that would really help
help
me yeah that's not that bad actually
this position
maybe oh interesting
move I take with the pawn and Knight D5
yeah that's that's not
good if I take with the queen yes Rook
D1 but probably I have
to pawn takes Knight D5 looks
but okay it would have corrected my Pawn
formation maybe I should have thought
about it for a
moment
H yeah I think I should have thought
about it for a moment but I
didn't okay um Queen took on
A5 cannot play
C4
and C5 is
hanging ugly position maybe I can get
the queens of the B
him yeah I'm maybe giving up this Pawn
but okay I can takes takes Rook C Bishop
C5 Rook C6 is
okay yeah Rook C yeah I thought isn't
this uh a bit of a problem now Bishop B4
Bishop
D2 and my Bishops all of a sudden come
to
life
okay Bishop C2 he will check me but
still check here King F7 and still this
is uh not very well
coordinated oh that one I didn't see
that
move E6 Rook E5 Bishop G7 isn't this ah
but okay after E6 he can give this
check
okay but okay I can I can play this
first if he takes E5 now Bishop G7 is
good and E6 I'm threatening maybe bishop
to B3 here I could have done Bishop B3
actually
H yeah what can you do with blitz
Jess um talking about Blitz oh I just
blundered E7 that's
bad I was I just wanted to say I need to
play a bit quicker and then I blunder
E7 okay I'm covering E7 and I have to
like switch gears totally
here 30
seconds I don't think that the position
is that much of a problem I think it
should
be efficiently
okay um Rook D1 no I can
take yeah I have to
take check here that's not
enough yeah it's I just have 14 seconds
and the position is not really great
yeah it really
isn't h
what did I do wrong there yeah I thought
I I should I probably missed some
chances when uh when I had the bishop
here it wasn't that bad really H Rook B7
but okay I'm I'm I'm lost here
anyway oo that wasn't bad that was bad
um around here I mean this this looks
looks untier but around here I shouldn't
be that bad the two Bishop should count
for something at least for something
like a draw but somehow he wasn't losing
material
here W
okay let's uh
let's do another game I really want to
win here yeah cannot lose all
games I usually do well in those live
streams but not that
time
um do you still like F3 against the
nimzo yeah that's a good
line for F3 is good against the nimzo I
mean it's a very um viable try for an
advantage and black should be okay it's
the nimzo after all but um it is um it
is good let's check who that is Mari
anguis I don't know it doesn't have a
name in there but it's from um from
Bosnia
let's play the
ru playing the closed main line
here oops Yeah D4 that's a really good
alternative to
H3 and um can lead to interesting
positions this for example is just a
sharp interesting position that um I
think white can definitely
play
with hopes uh to play for an
advantage yeah C5 very often after a
subsequent D5 we get something that
looks a lot like the
Bon this question what's what's the
worst blunder you ever made
H yeah
H what I really remember is that as a
kid yeah I blunder the Queen Once uh to
uh discover check which was really awful
it led to a defeat of my team that was
really terrible and I once um played
really badly in a team match where we
competed to uh get promoted to um to a
higher league and um it wasn't like a
single terrible move but I really played
like a and we missed uh the
qualification for that uh for that leak
because of that really
bad okay so let's see what I can do here
an interesting position of
course white has pushed with
G4 and has gained some space here on the
queen on the king
side but I I definitely have some
counterplay ideas
um D5 yeah I want to go D5 here after E5
I can take on on
C2 Knight
takes yeah I thought Knight takes C2
would be quite okay actually so let's do
that Knight takes and now I thought even
Knight E4 is
valid yeah I guess I don't want want to
retreat and um he always has this issue
of this hanging Knight it should this
should give me enough activity I
think Queen takes Rook takes maybe he
can do that Knight
D4 but it looks like it should be enough
activity yeah or that move so Bishop C4
Bishop
B4 there Poss Knight F5 at some
point not
easy the E3 Desperado does not lead to
anything ants Knight
F5 he's got Knight to
F5 for instance after Queen D5 this
Knight
F5 maybe not sure I don't want to spend
more time
here I try this bishop B4 and Bishop
C3 to quickly enter on the third rank
with my
Rook hoping for enough
compensation tricky can maybe play
Knight F5 just for activity but Knight
coming to
D6
no I mean of the of the blunders of
course I made my fair share of blunders
but it's just what what what's what's
what
um was was sticking in my head you know
my
mind those things that uh that really uh
they hurt
yeah um Queen H4 what exactly is the
move isn't this good
H okay I just play that F2 hangs you
know and
H3 I can take
here so I'm ending
my my series of losses winning a
game good to get a win in yeah not
playing like zero out of out of a ton
yeah
okay ah okay new new
game good good to have winning oh kill
88 kill 88 yeah that's the kind of name
we want great stuff I I think I lost
against this guy recently from a very um
from a very stupid game from a very
weird position and and so on so let's
see what we can do now the
nimzo I'm playing with Queen C2 a little
bit solidly and well people requested
the Kings game but yeah I should play E4
then right I will play E4 next time
yeah this line of the nimzo is a quite
safe
option white keeps um sound porn
formation and gets a decent development
that's always
um
advisable advisable
strategy um B6
really huh there is no trick
here like Knight G5 or something
probably
not let's just develop here and I don't
want to play A3 he has to take on C3
probably in any case maybe Knight E4 is
a move
sometimes a yeah maybe this
Knight B5 here isn't this an idea it's
Bishop
E4 okay I go for
that Knight to D6 Knight takes A7 those
are the
ideas next game one
F4 okay not to D2 please that was
close getting out of the
seile um there is a question ever played
Don but John bolamu difficult for me to
pronounce no not yet he's um also doing
YouTube he's um having a YouTube channel
that just as I am and we um just chatted
today and agreed to do um a video a dual
commentary where we both will do
commentary on the games will be on
shortly okay Knight E5 yeah attacking
The Rook this this looks dangerous but
this guy I mean 2,500 is really high in
5 minutes so he should uh should know a
little bit about the
game we take here this maybe Queen A8 or
silly stuff like
that but still maybe something weird is
happening to me I have a okay and queen
A8 yeah for Knight D6 ah how sick is
that that's a sick move
yeah takes and queen A8 Knight B5 for
Knight D6 check
H
okay is what what kind of account is
that let me check
this H okay I'm taking the benefit of
the
doubt I actually saw the saw this MTI as
well but but
still um yeah
so is there a counter attack some way to
Counterattack
here Knight B5 Knight D6 check King
moves Knight takes
B5 Queen B3 or
something H probably
not kn six
check
yeah it's probably not mattering very
much Queen B3 NTS Queen A5 huh just just
precisely Queen
A5 on Knight
D5 Knight D5 for what Knight F4
yes okay I'm res signing this game and
I'm going to report you to speed trap
just for for good
measure oops oh sorry oh I accidentally
clicked 15
minute and here King Crusher that's not
King's Crusher this is uh this is um
this is not Trion Gabriel you know yeah
I'm I I really um I really think that uh
there's relatively little cheating going
on but uh I mean I remember that um I
played against this guy earlier and it
was a very weird game so um yeah we can
uh we can you can just let him check for
just for for good measure as I said okay
here against this guy we have an Evans
Gambit and I always play with Bishop E7
this is uh the solid a solid
Choice D4 Knight A5 is is pretty decent
for
black yeah and now Bishop E2 or Bishop
D3 are moves I I play D6 in any case
yeah that's not KC it's um important to
know okay um I I this I still play D6
here
right
yeah he plays on dead positions I
remember there was a game posted where
he played Rook against Rook against set
John bolom
you but okay what what can you do it's
possible if you play without increment
yeah I have returned the pawn but I
don't mind that very much I have a solid
Pawn structure and I can develop with
Knight F6 and so on this is uh totally
okay for
black I can play B5 also get the the
queen
back and of course I'm attacking the
Knight he has to look at the
knight uh is ISC having some kind of
discounts on memberships for the
holidays yes um I think so but I don't
know the
details
um maybe the um we have an admin here
from the ISC can maybe tell you
something more about
it um okay so I pushed this queen back
but he has Bishop F4 in the in the
mix which is a bit
annoying I don't have a great
Square
H um got a question do you like Breaking
Bad you have a touch of Heisenberg I
actually noticed that today yeah that uh
if I if I grow some beard I look a
little bit like like Heisenberg with the
with the bald look yeah I
know I I actually love the show it's
really great breaking B is
excellent yeah I prepared Bishop D6 here
for as a reply to Bishop
F4 he played It Anyway which is probably
uh the right decision
so what I have here is a decent Pawn
structure but what white has is an extra
Pawn in the center so really really
probably a balanced
Affair um yeah I guess with the Knight
yeah the Knight on C4 is a little bit
unstable Knight
E7 okay I have to get ahead
here
uh okay I have to save my knight right I
wonder where to go F5 is the better
place for the bishop actually so I go to
B7 I got a question why don't you spark
a c cigarette like in the early days
yeah if you know my channel for a while
yeah you will know that I was a heavy
smoker but I quit quite a long time ago
now uh C4 is good that's a good move
H not so easy I would like to play
Bishop F5 of
course but he will take on C6 like here
on
C6
A6 yeah A6 does not look right but H I
have to play a move at some
point my C4 was strong yeah maybe I
should have done something about it okay
I would I really like to get in Bishop
F5
here yeah okay and now
maybe something like even C5 and B4 is
this too
ambitious I Rook d8 is good intending
Queen D7 or taking and queen D7 yeah
that's
good and I might also have tactical
tricks here yeah like Queen B6 Queen B6
Queen E3 is actually quite nice if I get
it
in oh it's preventing
that but still
it looks this looks kind of fishy yeah
we take
here I don't know it looks weird it
looks like there is some tactic that I
don't
see
H I don't see it yeah I don't see that
tactic there should be some tactic there
really should but I don't see
it damn okay I have to play
something um Knight D5 was my idea but
it's certainly not the best possible
continuation I overlooked something here
I'm totally
sure totally sure about
that um I can just take C6 yeah
yeah um
no at least I'm threatening some stuff
but he still can take takes C6 which he
doesn't
Okay W this is now tricky yeah Knight
F2 but I'm down to one minute
okay this looks this looks great though
what is your move
now okay let's win the
exchange and um I'm active yeah just my
knight is not really
playing okay I'm going to take
him Rook d8 for Rook D1 that looks
winning
actually there's also F4 hanging so it
looks that looks crushing Rook
D1 where is the where is the mate where
is the mate here
ah come
on let's win the end
game it should be
enough you can always M him later
yeah if you see a winning end
game
H I mean I really I have 30 seconds and
I'm not totally brain dead you can
resign but he he
doesn't come
on he's really just continuing like
nothing's ever going to happen here I
shouldn't what is he now he resigned
okay
okay that was weird I didn't think this
was a really good game I probably I
probably
um I probably missed some
stuff ah okay I really concentrated on
the game yeah I'm not looking so much at
the chat I wanted to really win a
game um people are talking about ways to
stop smoking yeah of course the main
thing is you really have to have to you
you need to want to stop but
um I
mean I I I did it um using this
Electronics electric cigarette but um
it's something that worked for me it is
not necessarily working for
everyone okay so let's
see does anybody else here like books by
yob orot if I pronounce that correctly
yes orot is very
good okay I have a classic here Eric
lron grandm yard bird and I'm going for
E4 if he plays E5 okay I would have
played the king's Gambit against him but
it didn't happen so let's play
F4
here okay we got a modern
defense
h
C
five I don't know the theory here
unfortunately and it's a little bit
difficult if you don't know
it but okay let's see what I can do he
went with
B5 I think E5 but here
okay it's a case of move first think
later okay takes on D4 I'm going to
recapture yeah I wonder maybe this Pawn
formation isn't that great
yeah but I'm not losing material if he
goes Bishop B7 I have Bishop uh
E4 just centralizing stuff or E6 yeah
maybe I can play
E6
tactic
E6 Bishop
D4 E6 Bishop F3 takes on
D7 isn't this good for
white E6 isn't this good for why though
am I overlooking stuff I'm taking here
now and
uh yeah yeah yeah I I saw that but I
thought that you cannot possibly play
like that it looks it looks really
fishy okay taking here and he takes with
the bishop yeah so I can give this
check for King
E8
huh there is no no win there that that's
amazingly unfair
I can of course just play for the attack
here and claim I have enough anyway but
I don't I don't see something really
great
here castling long isn't
helping okay I mean Queen D7 is not
helping me King E8 he wants to play
anyway I'm trying for C3 and maybe
castling short or castling long I mean I
didn't want to play castling long and T
takes on
C3 there will always be some
compensation in this
position oh that's
cheeky you're a greedy greedy
person or does he play for Queen A5
check no no he
doesn't so C3 is going to go back
there okay let's push
F5 what a tough
game yeah games against him are always
great yeah he's just uh fighting like no
tomorrow every game and uh we get get
great uh great games so
often um The Rook
B5 or just A4 yeah let's let's try
A4 of course he can play Queen A5 Queen
A4 but then I have Knight F6 check and
queen
B7 which is interesting taking is
totally out of the
question and if he takes E4 Queen takes
I have a Tempo on the bishop yeah okay
that's that's that's very very very
much of good compensation here if that's
the
sentence ah tough
stuff um the live streams are on YouTube
not after it ends but um the day after
because I always upload at the same time
and uh I won't change that most likely
okay B4 wow so Rook takes B4 he
plays Queen A5 or something like
that okay I'm going to take
here and go for Queen B7 and queen
B4 Queen B7 ah he can he can play Queen
C7 of course Ah that's stupid that is
stupid
stuff H okay but at least I get castling
in I totally forgot about Queen C7
that's stupid so how many pawns am I
down two pawns H
okay yeah it's still not totally
easy okay
A5
okay I was thinking Queen B7 again but
Rook Rook takes is actually
possible so this one attacking B4 and
threatening to take on
G6 it's still not not completely clear
at least I
hope this
move why he's got H5 maybe H got
H5 Queen
E4
okay uh Queen E1 Bishop C3 yeah that's
not so
good
h
yeah I have to play Rook A4 yeah I don't
like to do that but I have
to if he takes on F4 Rook A5 is actually
not that great for
him so maybe this is still somewhat
playable or did I overlook something
maybe I
did this is not that bad really for
me
Rook E1 for Bishop F5 N I can take here
better and we have got equal material
ladies and
gentlemen out of
nowhere yeah I don't want to get
checkmated
here
made
some air for the
king yeah this is um still slightly
uncomfortable because of E5
but yeah it is a draw of course
but this is the draw
but this is Blitz chess and he's got 30
seconds more on the clock and of course
it's not um like totally oh this is this
is nice get Rooks traded for the
draw that was luckier he could have won
that on time if he avoids The Rook trade
so tough stuff there's a question what
are your thoughts on more war zone
tournaments yeah I will do the odd war
zone tournament but it's just not that
great to play on that
server okay a new game um I think the
chat maybe crashed yeah I do a refresh
here I not sure if it crashed or
not this was a big battle against yard
bird as usual it's uh definitely never
boring yeah I don't really think uh that
uh we had a boring
game
ah
oops okay another game against zil
International Master come on go E5 yeah
I want the king's Gambit yeah people
want yep people want a king's Gambit
here we
go I have played the Kings Gambit
sometimes on my Channel with surprising
success and
um at least
um in those Blitz Games I had quite well
I sometimes had really rotten positions
but I scored fairly fairly well okay
this guy played the uh Fork beer counter
Gambit um what you can play like this
really this is compensation maybe it
is but if I don't take on C6 this is
entirely stupid right Knight D2 maybe I
can play Knight
D2
maybe Knight G2 for the
development I need a fork B I'm not sure
if if how this is
pronounced it is uh certainly I mean the
name of a player but I'm not sure if he
was German English or whatever could be
anything oh I completely Miss that
simple move uhoh yeah this is you know
if you don't play the Kings Gambit
regularly you sometimes miss those
simple tactics but I can play G3
right
G3 yeah you have to be I mean this is
the King's game but yeah let's see uh if
I go Knight
F3 yeah I mean I have good development
here Queen E7 I'll take G3 and if he
goes to H5 I can sacrifice The
Exchange yeah this you can do but I have
some development going Bishop C5
though okay we'll take
here Queen takes interesting I can take
I can play Bishop
E2 and I guess I will Bishop C5 I have
Rook F1 for Knight
C4 really uh wacky stuff but interesting
yeah and now I have to do something
creative
yeah Rook H5 threatening Rook
E5 use my better development I
guess so we've got a
typically Bonkers game in the king's
Gambit yeah
great that's fun
ah FAL bear a German speaking chess
master and journalist from Austria
Hungary then FAL bear is probably
right yeah Rook H5 sent him into Deep
Thoughts there are funny ideas now yeah
like Bishop E6 Rook E5 Queen moves and
F5 okay so he moved the queen away
so I can give this check
now but I don't know how good it really
is or I can take D5 I think I will take
D5 just because Knight C4 is such a nice
idea yeah Knight C4 I
guess my development is really fantastic
here but black is still fairly solid
yeah it's not like he's falling apart
quickly how do I get more into the game
Bishop E6 is maybe also coming with
Tempo it's not not easy at all Knight G5
maybe ah wow I really don't know this
kind of
stuff I mean not I don't I don't mean
opening Theory or so but I mean the kind
of position it's not my my type of Chess
so I have to really find my way around
this
position Bishop E7 probably is what I
would play
here trying to get
development Bishop E7 that looks nice H6
I have Knight E4 and other ideas yeah
this move Knight E4 yeah he he might
just
Castle Bishop H5 maybe and then there's
G6 Knight
D6 I don't know where
wow this is difficult
stuff
still Knight
D6 but that's not leading too much does
it uh I don't know I have to play a move
it's really too too difficult for
me yeah okay Queen I thought that maybe
I can do something now on F7 and
H7 what about Bishop C4 moves like that
Bishop D3 there
G6 that's not going to
win Bishop C4
maybe ah this whole position looks kind
of kind of
shaky but
okay we have to play this
now I wonder like H6 is The Rook takes
H6 wow this is wild
stuff yeah I thought Rook I thought this
move
here is quite an idea threatening on
H7 he can give the check now oh he
actually has um an additional
check okay let's go here he's got Rook
E2 H he's got Rook
E2 King
here
okay wow Queen B6
check but I don't see a m and I'm
threatening on H7 yeah and G6 I have
Rook G6 so this is kind of uh kind
of
tricky Queen wow Queen B6 check King G2
Rook E2 check King H1 and I don't see a
check for him and G6 loses due to Rook
G6
F5 is not
possible how is he covering
this is this really winning for white I
have a hard time to believe that but at
the moment I don't see how he
defends I don't see how he defends at
the
[Music]
moment Bishop maybe bishop F5 or
something H but it does not seem to
work
huh I I think I'm winning here I think
I'm winning but okay um I can also go to
F1 here
actually is this better
maybe after to
F1 ah then he's got Rook
H2 he's got Rook H2 I have to go here
Queen B6 check King
H1 can give Rook H2 check Queen F2 King
H1 and I'm
defending
wow I think it's working King F1 he had
Rook H2 yeah to cover H7 I can easily
Overlook
that 35 seconds left this is the problem
maybe but I think I think if I'm meeting
him it's not mattering much then the
game is just ending right
away Queen B6 check King H1 it's it's
really
winning
wow it's winning
great
um
oh no
Checkmate okay let's let's take this
first
this Knight takes I just I just take the
bishop you
know I mean I take the The Rook is what
I wanted to say just take the material
now
check
here that really should do the
trick
um don't tell me there's no win here
that would be
frustrating 5 Seconds no
no W I won on
time
that was tough but a really cool game to
finish the session yeah the king's
Gambit wow so um I really I absolutely
have to check this game out
here
um Let me let me let me have a look here
I
need I have to check how this this is
this is really really to be
evaluated am I winning in this position
I mean I'm cheating here I'm starting
the
computer yeah it's plus five in fact
amazing
yeah this is just great yeah he has no
way to stop this mate
here the what he played was actually the
best continuation which is just plus
five
so really
nice um okay let me let me check I have
to
look at some questions here I really had
to had to check
um there was a question about the the
titles of national master and candidate
Master yeah National Master is not a
feeded title um National Master is a
title that is sometimes given out by
chess federations um for example by the
USCF the US Chess Federation they have
this National Master title I'm not sure
about the requirements the requirements
I think are different um from country to
Country um and the candidate Master is
an official feed the title that's a
different thing for a candidate Master
you need to be rated
2,200 the national Master however is
something that is differing from from
country to Country so there might be a
national master of let's say uh I mean
lonstein or something like that and uh
you know maybe need 1,800 to get that
well in the US you might need 2,100 or
200 or what not so it's different and
candidate Master is is a worldwide
recognized title the same as um IM FM
and
GM um yeah National Master is just a
good thing to have but it's it's hard to
evaluate it's like um can be anything in
a
way
um so there any questions that I that I
missed
um another game please I just checked
out now well that's that's late you want
you want one more game yeah maybe one
more game let's let's I like to play you
know I can play one more game but I then
have to definitely quit this is against
ricardi Grand Master from U Argentina so
one bonus game and then I definitely
have to quit otherwise I won't manage to
run to the grosses I need to get stuff
for my breakfast
tomorrow so really just one more
game so we have the the main line here
of the Spanish okay playing with D3
that's one of those old lines that
nevertheless have um
yeah have some some Merit of
course yeah I guess to
B7 what I'm doing is I'm going for this
typical
regrouping Bishop to
G7 can be played in many lines of the
Roy Lopez and one main point of this is
that F5 is um
controlled um okay he's opening up the
position it's so quite surprising I
think just when I'm ready to play Bishop
to G7 it's uh it's a little
bit I don't know it's it's um a
surprising
timing um
okay so what are you doing there with
your Queen
H I can play D5
just blasting everything open the thing
is that I'm better developed in this
position so it cannot be that terrible
for
me I just uh not sure what the best way
is okay let's let's go like that and
then for Knight
E4 going for total development
here Knight
D7 yeah let's do that let's do it like
that
um um there's a question if you heard of
the TCC tournament that's this computer
chess tournament I think uh no I never
looked at that very much I might of
course I I use
um I use the computers for analysis and
they are great help but
I don't uh don't like so much to um to
watch computer versus computer games it
feels um I don't know it's not so
interesting in a way because machines
playing um against each other is a
little bit pointless I mean would you
watch Robots playing uh I don't know
football against one another I I don't
think I
would
okay
um do you consider worldwide fans to
select the timing of live broadcast this
is a broadcast um which is initiated by
the ICC so um it's really u a time that
they select I think it's it's a pretty
good
time um someone asked about Chess base
and they remarked that chess Bas is an
expensive program and too
expensive
um yeah H it depends it depends a little
bit there are various packages of Chess
Bas and to be perfectly honest I think
that the there is a download version
that you can buy for about
€100 um it does not have any additional
databases just a pure program and I
think this is actually fair value if you
ask me I don't want to do any
um advertisement or something for chess
B it's just like I think this is a
decent uh price to pay for the
software
um what I do I think about the Trump and
tournament CH the Trump psky is a good
opening it's simply a good opening can
be uh can be employed really why not
there's no reason not to um okay but
what about this here he's playing Bishop
H6
H let's try to get rid of this
don't like
it when there's a bishop on
H6 yeah he has some activity here but it
shouldn't be sufficient for an edge at
least okay Bishop I don't get this move
to be
honest what is he playing here after
this I'm attacking I mean okay he can he
can play stuff like Queen
G5 yeah he
can Rook E5 that's a very weak back rank
here Rook E5 has Queen
C4 okay let's do that
Queen G5 that looks really
weird but probably it's just it's just
playable Queen G5 I don't see a
reputation of this move of course F6 is
just violating the chess rules quite
clearly E3 maybe E3 takes Bishop H6
Queen
H6 and queen
G3 allowing Bishop F7 probably
not okay going to take there and now
think about it is there a way to use the
somewhat misplaced pieces this is this
is hanging
yeah okay I'm down on time yeah I'm down
on
time I can play Bishop
C4 but I have E3 then and then I can
take on G2 yeah that's in fact a good
idea I have to be cautious there's
always tricks like Bishop F7 coming so
Bishop C4 Queen B2 there's Bishop F7
and I mean okay maybe that's not really
winning but
it is
dangerous maybe has to play something
like Queen E3
here
maybe Rook e five there was some
tactical tricks someone has Wroten has
written
that the back rank was very
weak
Rook B8 yeah I'm greedy I want to take
on
B2 if he lets
me yeah can I take the this this now or
is there some Wicked double attack there
maybe
is Bishop F4 but I drop
back okay I'm going to take
it it looks a bit risky
somehow Queen F4 Rook f8 it looks risky
yeah Bishop F7 Rook F7 is not a
problem it's good that McQueen is on the
long diagonal yeah this is really
helping okay so he's attacking the
bishop uh
trying to use this pin not sure if this
is a good idea it might might
backfire it might
backfire here it is it it it did
backfire it was tough to lose this game
but I managed
yeah
uh
okay I I will show you why Bishop Rook
G6 and now I can resign yeah I was just
um I was just a pawn up here but I I
screwed this
up around here black is just better I
think but
um it's not not easy it's not easy to
play
really isn't okay so I did one bonus
game and um yeah I would never play
Queen B8 yeah I tried to win
guys I can do all kinds of
stuff okay um we already played a little
bit longer than was was planned more
than 70 minutes um I really need to to
wrap this up now because well frankly I
need breakfast tomorrow
morning okay I'm glad you joined um as
usual many uh many people participating
in the chat thanks a lot for that and if
you're only caught part of it then um
remember that this will be posted on the
archive the twitch archive for the IC
and also on my channel thanks a lot
bye